lara ayache avocate au barreau de paris
et représentante du syndicat gilet jaune
bonjour la rai h merci de répondre à nos
questions à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre aujourd'hui à une
manifestation aux abords des lieux de
pouvoir malgré l'interdiction de
manifester ou bien un cortège sur
l'itinéraire autorisée par la préfecture
de police de paris
alors merci de me permettre de
m'exprimer sur ma compagne dans un
premier lieu je le ce à quoi il faut
s'attendre effectivement aujourd'hui
c'est maintenant d'un rassemblement
statique aux abords de la place pavée
allées du louvre dans la mesure où ce
qui a été interdite par le préfet de
police suivant arrêté 16 décembre
dernier
c'est une des trois cartes du cortège
les trois quarts du portage puisque le
seul à seul le cirque parcours autorisé
est à peu près 300 m de manifestations
allaient allant du n'a pas su palais du
louvre jusqu'au pont d or ce qui
représente quelques centaines de mètres
ce qui n'a aucun intérêt effectivement
pour une manifestation de cette de cette
nature donc c'est vraiment une
interdiction quasi totale du parcours
qui avait été déclarée toute légalité
par le syndicat les gilets jaunes ont
que je représente les intérêts qui a été
accordé par la préfecture de police
cet arrêté avait été attaquée devant le
juge des référés aux prés le tribunal
administratif de paris qui a considéré
que l'arrêté adopté par de la préfecture
étaient était parfaitement légal ce que
nous à ce que le syndicat conteste très
fermement a contesté très fermement
devant la juridiction en raison de la
disproportionnalité si vous voulez de
l'interdiction qui a été prononcée par
la préfecture de police se regardent du
nombre de manifestants attendus qui
s'élève à peu près avant 2000 de moins
de 1000 personnes au regard d'un port
parcours alternatif qui aurait pu être
proposées par la préfecture de police et
qui qu'il a été mais dans des conditions
irrespectueux si vous voulez
certaines manifester puisque la
préfecture de police au terme de
négociations assez conséquente a estimé
que le parcours inca parcours alternatif
en de la manifestation est envisageable
mais sur un périmètre cantonné à l'est
parisien
un allant de la place du palais du
louvre jusque jusqu'à la bastille
jusqu'à jusqu'au 11ème arrondissement
après un prêt persie ce qui ne couvrait
pas du tout si vous voulez même pas une
partie des lieux symboliques devant
lesquelles le syndicat des fonds publics
mais faut s'attendre quand même à des
manifestations malgré les interdictions
devant ces lieux symboliques du lin
pouvoir matignon l'elysée le conseil
d'état non non car lui l'enfant dit can
2012 que je représente entend agir dans
une secte cadre légal et dans le secteur
4 de l'autorisation
même si elle est au contact et un père
tue d'arguments juridiques sérieux et
font des violences sommes tout à l'heure
absolument pas absolument pas partie à
cette manifestation
pas du tout en même temps que la loi
futurs hits et globale
une gestation pacifique avec pas les
participants à la radio je me permets de
vous pouvez vous venez d'évoquer la loi
sécurité globale justement jeu
quelles sont les revendications
aujourd'hui des gilet jaune
le hérissé le pouvoir d'achat ou la
lutte contre les violences policières et
justement la loi sécurité globale on s'y
perd un petit peu en impression d'avoir
un melting-pot de requêtes c'est quoi
les revendications aujourd'hui la dg les
jaunes les revendications des déchets
des jeunes et de mettre en place un
contre-pouvoir social c'est un
contre-pouvoir social syndical qui est
revendiqué par les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui instaurant plus de davantage
de justice sociale un vous avez très
certainement entendre l'un des
représentant légal de l'union syndicale
dans votre journal
tout à l'heure qui vous l'expliquera
mieux que moi mais il n'y a pas de
melting-pot si vous voulez en ce sont
des revendications sociales syndicales
classique mettant l'individu l'être
humain au centre des décisions
gouvernementales par l'instauration d'un
harris et par plus d'égalité davantage
d'égalité donc elle pas du tout de
melting-pot c'est vraiment une justice
sociale qui revendiquait par sept par
cette union mais la manifestation n'est
pas centralisé sur la loi sécurité
globale absolument pas d'où est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à une convergence des
luttes avec les opposants à la sécurité
globale
on sait qu'à l'époque y avait une
convergence en tous les cas on parlait
beaucoup d'une convergence des luttes
avec les opposants à la réforme des
retraites par exemple si vous voulez
[Musique]
représentants légaux des syndicats dont
je suis la défense des intérêts de
s'exprimer sur cette thématique
mais rien n'est certain si vous aimez
les domaines de revendication de minutes
2 millions c'est le cas j'en ai beaucoup
plus vaste que la sécurité n'est pas du
tout le même
là ce sont des larmes c'est également le
dernier week-end avant avant noël les
commerçants ont été largement impacté on
ne sait par les diverses violences ces
dernières années en marche des
différentes manifestations
il ya également la crise la crise
sanitaire évidemment est ce que vous
comprenez les petits commerçants qui ont
peur aujourd'hui pour ce samedi
de devoir fermer boutique à cause
d'éventuelles nouvelles violences qui
leur empêche serait de faire recette
tout à fait c'est la raison pour
laquelle le syndicat avait proposé un
parcours alternatif à lyon a lyon la
liberté de manifester et leurs équipes
et de leurs revendications syndicales
pour contourner les rues où sont situés
les petits commerçants et ne pas les
impacts et il y avait un trajet
alternatif que le tribunal nous a
entendus sur ce point là un trajet
alternatif entre la place du palais du
louvre et les avanies bain en longeant
les quais côté côté rive gauche de paris
qui permettait de contourner la zone
commerciale et ne pas impacter les
petits et petits commerçants pour des
motifs que nous ignorons aujourd'hui
puisque nous nous attendons à l'
ordonnance qui va être rendu par le
tribunal administratif
ce parcours là n'a même pas été validés
très certainement pour des raisons de
troubles à l'ordre public que nous
contestons contestons encore aujourd'hui
et nous initierons partie de manifester
puisse être respecté
merci la rai âge d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que je vous êtes
avocate au barreau de paris et vous
représentez le syndicat ad gilet jaune